[MUSIC PLAYING]
PAUL RASHIDI: Hello, everyone.
Thanks for joining
our Hangout.
My name's Paul Rashidi,
and this is Jeff Sham.
We're members of the
DFP API team.
We're excited to host another
API integration Hangout, this
time with Yieldex.
They integrate with DoubleClick
to optimize
publishers' revenue.
Today, we have distinguished
members of Yieldex's team.
Tom Shield's the founder
of Yieldex.
Without further ado, I'll give
the floor to Tom, who'll
introduce the team and then talk
about Yieldex's product.
TOM SHIELDS: Great.
Good morning.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Tom Shields.
I'm co-founder of Yieldex.
We started Yieldex about five
years ago, and it helped
publishers optimize revenue
through inventory forecasting
and analytics.
And we'll obviously talk a
little bit more about that as
we go through.
Previous to this, I was a
founder of a company called
Net Gravity, which also became
a Google product, ultimately.
So I've been in the ad tech
business for a long time.
Craig?
CRAIG MILLER: I'm
Craig Miller.
I am the Chief Technology
Officer here at Yieldex.
And I've been intricately
involved in the buildout of
all our tech items.
JOSH BERNSTEIN: I'm
Josh Bernstein.
I'm a solutions consultant
here at Yieldex.
And I spent some time
at Google as well.
TOM SHIELDS: Fantastic.
All right, let's dive
in and talk a
little bit about Yieldex.
All righty.
So, let's start with--
we'll talk a little bit about
the product, give you a little
demo of the product, give you a
taste of what it can do, and
then, obviously, we're going
to talk a lot about the API
and integration because
that's why we're here.
So what do we do?
We increase publisher revenue.
We help the publishers increase
revenue by doing big
data analytics.
Big data is like my
favorite buzzword.
It's one of those things on
buzzword bingo you check off
because everybody says it.
But we process terabytes of
data, and we help people
understand how to forecast,
how to manage, and how to
price their ad inventory.
And we do this across display.
We do it across mobile.
We do it across video.
And we work with a lot of
different players in the ad
technology ecosystem.
We work with a number of
very large clients.
Here's some of the clients that
we work with, ranging
from "Wall Street Journal" and
the "New York Times" to NBC
and ComCast to more specialized
ones like Pandora,
cars.com, Weather Channel.
So these are all clients that
are getting a lot of value out
using the Yieldex system to
understand their inventory,
forecast it, and price it.
So we've gotten a lot of
traction within the industry.
And a lot of these, of course,
are also DFP clients.
So we consider ourselves the
next logical piece in the
publisher ad stack.
So for most publishers, they've
built out a stack that
looks like an ad server, which
might be a DFP or another one.
It might be an order management
system, or maybe
it's a homegrown order
management systems, such as a
DSM, or Operative, or FatTail
or something.
And then now many of them are
adding data management and
third-party data systems.
I know that DFP's been working
on one of these.
And there's Demdex, and BlueKai,
and, Lotame, Krux,
and all these other
ones as well.
So we find ourselves on top of
this stack, helping with the
inventory forecasting, and the
management, and the pricing.
And we integrate with all these
other pieces within the
stack to unify all that data
and give the publisher the
insights that they
need to maximize
their overall revenue.
So just to talk specifically
about some of the integration
partners-- of course, we
integrated with DFP and DSM,
and then a number of other ad
servers on the list, a number
of other order management
systems on the list.
And then the number of data
management platforms are
rolling out as we speak.
So we find ourselves integrating
a lot of this data
together and giving
the publishers the
insights they need.
And we'll talk to you a little
bit about the insights.
The basic idea behind our
technology is that the
publishers have been able
to sell content.
They've been able to sell
what they have.
But they haven't been able to
figure out how to sell other
kinds of things that
relate to that.
So they've been able
to sell content.
And they can see availability
and sold.
But as soon as you start
targeting things like that
behavioral targets, or
demographic targets, or things
like age and gender, you start
to run into a problem where
the inventory is getting
fragmented.
You don't understand how
things are overlapping.
And it's very, very difficult
to know what
things are going on.
So as soon you start getting
pictures like this, and this
is a picture that's very
familiar to most ad operations
and yield management people,
then you need try and figure
out, how do you tease apart all
this and really understand
what's going on.
So you need to be able
to see the overlaps.
And you need to be able to see
simple things like just what's
available for each one of these
different segments,
taking into account the fact
that a lot of the other
segments have been sold.
So that's the very basis
of what we do.
And once you have the capability
to do that kind of
thing, then there's a lot of
market capabilities that you
build on top of it in terms of
the ability to do pricing and
management.
So just to give one case study
of a news publisher looking at
year-over-year revenue, as they
looked at their top seven
products that they sell
on an ongoing basis--
these are high CPM, high
sell-through products, as a
general rule--
they were able to dramatically
increase their revenue and
their sell-through on all of
these high-value products and
have pretty dramatic impact
on their overall revenue.
What's important about
this to understand
is, this in not REM.
This is not the low CPM stuff
that we're trying to bring
from $0.50 to $1,
or $1 to $1.50.
This is their highest-value
inventory.
These are the products
that generate the
most revenue for them.
So this is the $15 and $20 CPM
stuff that they sell very
effectively, that already
generates 80% or 90% of their
overall revenue.
So if you can increase that
by 35% or 50%, that has a
dramatic impact on their overall
revenue number and
their overall top line number.
So it's a very powerful thing
once a publisher really
bookrates it and starts
to use it.
Now what I'm going to do is, I'm
going to turn this over,
actually, to Josh.
Oh, hold on a second--
screenshare.
And I'm going to let Josh talk
more specifically about
exactly what the product
can do for you.
JOSH BERNSTEIN: Thanks, Tom.
So I'm going to jump back into
the presentation and show you
some high-level concepts as
far as how the product
addresses these challenges
that Tom's talking about.
And just wait for that
to queue up.
So what we have here, basically,
these five bubbles
represent the different areas
of the product where we can
help publishers in
their workflow.
So as we go through the product,
we can see how, from
a sales manager's perspective,
we can help publishers drive
more revenue.
From an availability and
capacity section, we can find
more inventory to sell.
From a delivery management
perspective, we can help add
on, subtract, and get their
assets delivered on time and
on schedule.
From product delivery, we can
help the inventory team find
new products to sell.
And from the price optimization
perspective, we
can help publishers determine
what the best price is to be
selling their inventory.
So if we look at the sales
management piece, it's really
about helping publishers get
the right information, the
right availability, at the
point of sale so that
salespeople know what inventory
they have to sell.
With integrations like we have
with DSM, we can take our
highly accurate forecasting
numbers that incorporate both
revenue forecasts and CPM or
impression forecasts with the
deals a salesperson is looking
at and push those numbers
right into DSM at the point of
sale, so when they're setting
up those line items they
know exactly what
they have to sell.
From a capacity, forecasting,
and availability--
we have a UI where we can easily
jump into our tool and
run the numbers.
But if you have RFPs that you
use or templates that you use,
if your salespeople just want
to jump into Excel and pull
some numbers, you can use our
API and pull those numbers
directly into Excel or a web UI
customized for those users
to make it very easy for them
to find the numbers they're
looking for with simple
templates
that they can be using.
For delivery management and
pacing campaigns, you can
literally see how the campaigns
are delivering and
easily identify campaigns that
are under goal either by
revenue or impressions.
And when folks run these
metrics, if you have campaigns
that have a lot of revenue
behind goal and less
impressions, it can help you
focus your ad operations to
campaigns that'll drive more
revenue with the least impact
on other campaigns.
From a product discovery
perspective, you can look at
all of your inventory on a nice
bubble chart and see,
before you ever deliver a
campaign, which one might get
the most uniques, have the
highest click-through rate,
drive the most revenue, really
determine the value of that
inventory before you start to
sell it, so when you do sell
it, the advertisers who buy
that inventory know that
they're going to get
good results.
And as these campaigns are
delivering and you're setting
up different inventory, how you
price it determines how
much revenue you're going
to make as a publisher.
So by tracking the different
prices for your inventory and
tracking that against revenue,
you can find out what prices
drive in the most revenue and
drive in the most demand.
And when you raise their price
and the demand starts
dropping, you can really see
where that inflection point is
and make sure you try not to
cross that next time to keep
revenue coming in
the front door.
So now what I want to do is
actually show you the UI and
run some reports.
So here we have the UI.
This where you can come in an
run a lot of your reports.
You can see in reports there's a
lot of customization you can
do with the product.
Now, some reports I was just
showing you in the UI is just
be able to target against
different graphs.
You can switch to data views,
line charts, bubble charts.
It's all available
in this system.
Now, the way we usually go about
it is have different
saved reports, so you can come
in, and you can load up the
sales manager reports.
This particular report,
we're at high
sell-through inventory.
Utilization basically refers to
sell-through and the discount.
So where publishers have high
sell-through of 95-plus
percent, this particular
publisher was seeing high
discounts as well.
So by having visibility to this
information, publishers
can set up business rules to
say when our inventory is
greater than 80% sold
out, we want to
cut back on our discount.
Looking at some of the other
reports, we can do
availability reports.
Looking at these all by the
different products that a
salesperson might look at, we
can see what are the available
impressions and the
available revenue
if I sold that product.
So available impressions are
green, which is typically what
publishers look at.
if publishers start looking at
available revenue for each
deal, you can see here in these
blue dots represents how
much revenue you can make by
selling that inventory.
So where a salesperson might
have typically focused on
sports enthusiasts, now maybe
they'll focus on people who
travel because there's more
potential revenue.
And you can go through a
lot of these reports.
You can do product discovery,
looking at uniques and
click-through percentage.
You can do pricing optimization
where I show the
inflection point for all
these predefined
products and inventory.
Or maybe you want to come
in here and just
run a dynamic forecast.
You can have all those targets
predefined, but we also have
tools where you can come
in and run your own
availability lookup.
So I come in here, and just on
the fly, I can say I want to
look at my US inventory.
And I can come in and type in
the country I'm looking for.
I can come in and
choose the size.
So maybe I'll only want to
look in my leaderboards.
And they'll pull those up.
And then something else I can
do that's really interesting
from certain perspectives is
being able to run more than
one forecast at a time.
So I would hope that just for
the next week, I want to see
what I can run for the
holiday season.
And this particular advertiser
is looking for things that
they want to take over a
whole day for certain
parts of the inventor.
So I can look at day and
week as a variant.
So I can actually run a forecast
for every single day
of the week, all at once, and
see what is the best day that
I want to set in my inventory.
So by doing this, by choosing
the country and the different
targeting criteria, I'm setting
up what content I want
to serve it to.
And by using the things like a
target variance, I actually
run seven different forecasts,
one for each day of the week.
And this is all for a
completely customized inventory.
And you can see here, in a few
seconds, I just ran seven
different forecasts.
So this way, I can literally
come in, and I can see Friday,
Monday, Saturday, Sunday-- all
the different days, the
available impressions, and
the total capacity.
So I can go back to my
advertiser and tell them which
is the best day I can be
selling my inventory.
So that's the quick demo.
Now I'm going to turn
it back to Craig.
We'll talk a little bit more
our API technology.
CRAIG MILLER: So as Josh
mentioned, I'm here to talk a
little bit about how our
technology works, how we work
with the DoubleClick API for
publishers, and how we
leverage that API to access all
the data we need to offer
the product functionality
that we offer.
I'll jump right into the
screen show here.
We are not sharing.
Little technical difficulties.
So here at Yieldex, and
throughout our product, we
consider accessibility of the
data that we've built out to
be critical to the application
and usability of our product
for our customers.
We do this by offering charts
and graphs as well as analytic
tools on top of all of the data
to make sure that that
data is most accessible to end
business users within the
customer performance.
In addition to that, we offer
data in low-level
accessibility forms such as
Excel or CSV formats.
That's all available
via exporting
throughout the product.
Finally, we offer APIs to let
our customers integrate our
data back into any systems that
they feel make this data
most accessible and most
understandable to the business
processes that they have
in their environment.
That could be anything from
custom user interfaces to
third-party integration, such
as an operative or any
existing reporting or BI systems
that the customer has.
So we offer very powerful APIs,
analytics tools, and
data access capabilities
within our platform.
This is absolutely critical
to our success.
Yieldex works by effectively
connecting out and reaching
out to all of your ad servers,
order management systems, data
management platforms to
integrate all the data into a
unified environment that are
required to fully understand
the inventory model within
a given publisher.
To do that, we obviously need
very rich connectors and
accessibility via APIs and data
feeds from each of our
partner vendors.
Once we acquire that data, we
crunch or distill that into
our proprietary inventory
models.
On top of that, we take all of
the historic feeds from the ad
servers themselves and look at
each and every one of the
impressions historically.
Finally, we forecast that using
our patented algorithms
and then predict or simulate the
ad server delivery on top
of that inventory model.
Ultimately, our goal is to make
that data accessible in
the ways we mentioned earlier
in order to allow the
publisher to make better
business decisions and thereby
maximize the revenue.
With the Dart for Publishers
platform, we've actually
leveraged the new APIs.
In fact, many of those new APIs,
we go very rich and deep
to pull up all of the order,
line item, and corresponding
targeting data to understand
exactly how the demand that
those orders represent are
trafficked or targeted against
our inventory model.
We do this each and every day,
and, in some cases, multiple
times a day or every one of our
customers using the Dart
for Publishers platform.
So we've actually leveraged the
new API and found definite
benefits in this over other
integrations that we have in
providing the services that
we have for our customers.
So one of the key benefits that
we've noticed with using
the new API is related to the
API performance itself.
We are now able to import,
throughout the given course of
the day, the campaign
trafficking data and targeting
constraints in significantly
improved time than previously.
Typically, it's now less than
10 minutes, whereas
previously, we'd seen
times up to an hour.
And to do that, we're actually
leveraging the filtering
capabilities of PQL
in the new API.
One of the other key benefits
that we've seen in moving to
Dart for Publishers premium
is the log and
data transfer system.
So previously, we had some
limitations related to how we
can access the data that we
require to fully understand
the inventory on behalf
of our publishers.
And our publishers have had to
do things such as use the U
equals tag to ensure that
the data that we need is
transferred in the logs.
Using the new login transfer,
this is no longer required,
which is a decided benefit for
Yieldex and our customers in
that there's less
configuration.
We're also able to access that
log data more frequently and
much more quickly throughout the
day than we had been able
to previously.
And finally, being able to get
logs at a more granular level
allows us to actually build
better functionality around
how we handle date and
time zones for our
international clients.
One of the best things about
the new API for Yieldex has
really been that we're able
to do more out-of-the-box
reporting, leading to less
implementation time, less
setup and configuration by our
services organization when
they engage with
a given client.
That's a key benefit for Yieldex
that allows us to
realize revenue ourselves
much more quickly.
We also have noticed that we get
much cleaner data out of
the new API given that there's
more formalization, more
structure, around the keywords
and key values and the data
that we actually receive.
That cleaner data also helps our
implementation teams get
up and running and offer the
data benefits that we offer to
our customers more quickly.
Internally, our development
organization has been able to
benefit from a better
development paradigm.
We find that the new DoubleClick
APIs and their
service-oriented architecture
give us a better development
paradigm with cleaner
code and easier
frameworks to develop against.
So many of our customers are
using the current DFP system,
and therefore, Yieldex
is able to offer
them an upgrade process.
When we go about the upgrade
process to the new DFP, we
offer seamless continuity of
reporting across the old and
new systems.
Our customers benefit from all
of the historic data that they
benefited from in the Yieldex
platform in arrears and
historically, and then going
forward once they get to the
new DFP system.
In order to do that, we link the
line item level data from
the old system to
the new system.
And we also link all of the
targeting constraints that the
publishers apply to those line
items that constrain the
delivery against our inventory
forecasts.
In order to enable that, we
switch data connectors
seamlessly on behalf of the
given customer from the old
API to the new API.
That happens during the cutover
period where we phase
data from the legacy system
to the new DFP system.
That takes, effectively, about
seven days, during which time
the Yieldex system remains
available, and customers
benefit from all of the
analytics and historic
reporting that they've been able
to perform as well as our
given forecasts looking
in the future on the
previous DFP system.
After seven days, we have new
forecasts up and ready to go
and all of the delivery
predicted
for the new DFP system.
And customers move on
seamlessly, benefiting from
the Yieldex environment on top
of the new DFP platform.
Any configuration changes that
may be required are performed
by the Yieldex services
organization.
So it's critical for customers
and their organization
representatives here at Yieldex
to work together to
understand any tagging changes
or targeting restructuring
that is going to occur
when moving
to the new DFP platform.
So that's how Yieldex works
with the new DFP.
JEFF SHAM: Great.
PAUL RASHIDI: Great.
Thanks, Craig.
I'm excited to see how you
guys like the new API.
I was wondering if you could
talk a little bit more about
how you're using PQL to reduce
your load times?
CRAIG MILLER: Sure, sure.
So one of the things that I
mentioned is we have to go
very deep and very wide and
effectively pull in all of the
publishers' orders, campaigns,
line items from the API and
all of the targeting constraints
related to that.
So a critical aspect of that is
knowing which campaigns are
active, which campaigns are
recent or have undergone
changes, and we do that using
some of the PQL filtering
relating to date, time ranges.
So we actually go ahead and
request, rather than doing
what we used to do with the
old API, where we'd
effectively start with an
advertiser and then traverse
the tree of all the campaigns
related to that advertiser,
interrogating one at a time,
those items making cross-wire
calls to do so.
And that's really what we did at
the time to determine if a
campaign or line item was active
and ready to be pulled
into Yieldex.
That took a significant amount
of time as each individual API
call was made.
Under the new system, what we
do is use PQL filtering to
effectively say let me fetch all
of the campaigns and line
items that need to
be processed in
one given API call.
We were then able to catch that
on the Yieldex side in
memory and then effectively make
a couple of finer-grain
calls to a much more limited
extent to pull back the
individual line item data and
process that into the Yieldex,
what we call import model,
which then backs our
predictions and our
forward-facing predictive
analytics as well as add
dimensional data to our
historic-facing analytics.
PAUL RASHIDI: Great.
JEFF SHAM: That's really
interesting to know.
So that talks about downloading
data or fetching data.
Do you use PQL for updating
or pushing data at all?
CRAIG MILLER: You know,
Yieldex is currently a
read-only system.
So what we do is we actually
take a reflection of all of
the data in what we consider
to be the system of record,
which is the customer's ad
servers and order management
systems, and we unify those into
a given model that allows
them to run very deep analytics
about how those
campaigns and flights both have
consumed the inventory
that the publisher has
historically and predicted for
the future.
So to do that, we take a
snapshot of all of the traffic
campaigns and all of the
upcoming proposals out the
variety of trafficking systems
and order management systems
the publisher has, unify those
into one given model, predict,
simulate the future, and then
allow the publishers to access
that information through
our analytics APIs.
We don't require write-access
to do that.
We're a read-only system.
And what we've found, the value
of our system, we've
talked about some of the
customers that have seen huge
increases in revenue was because
we can provide real
actionable information to the
operations team, to the Yield
team, and to the sales team
to help them price more
effectively, so they know when
they should discount and when
they shouldn't discount, when
they should raise prices or
not-- that has a major
impact on revenue.
What they have available to sell
or what other things that
they should sell at this
time of trying to
consummate a deal.
If something's sold out, what
other things can be proposed.
And then at the time of
delivery, how do we make sure
this thing is actually
going to deliver.
What is competing with it?
How do we move things around to
make sure that we're going
to collect all that revenue?
So you think about the key value
propositions that we're
providing, and they're not
things that require us to push
back in the DFP.
They're things that provide
information to the people who
are doing these jobs.
JEFF SHAM: Great.
PAUL RASHIDI: Yeah, thanks.
So another thing that I was
wondering if you could go into
a little bit more detail about
is it's very important for
upgrading publishers around
continuity of
their reporting data.
And your system allows
reporting to
cross the upgrade boundary.
So I was just curious if you
could talk a little bit about
how you're able to do that
from a technological
perspective.
CRAIG MILLER: Yeah,
so absolutely.
We completely agree.
And we hear from our customers
that it is critical to provide
seamless data across the systems
in general to help
smooth the transition.
So what we do is we work with
Google to effectively get a
line-item level mapping from
the ad flight IDs in the
previous DFP system into the
new DFP system as those IDs
change and work with our
services team here at Yieldex
to perform a mapping,
internally, that allows those
same flights to connect
to one another.
As our import process runs on
a periodic basis against the
DoubleClick API, we're able to
pull in any new targeting
constraints related to
those line items.
And our system has some internal
data constructs that
allow for different versions
of targeting to occur over
time, either in what we call our
reporting products or on
what we call our traffic
or order line products.
And so our system connects up
all of that data seamlessly
for our customers once we have
the mapping that we receive
from Google and we do some
services work to enable that
on our end.
That takes us really
just a couple days.
And then our forecasting
algorithms, we need
effectively to see the new
DoubleClick traffic on the new
ad server for approximately a
week to be able to start to
predict those into the future
and provide very accurate
forecasts and overlap models for
the publisher to run those
analytics that allow them to
make the better business
decisions and maximize
their revenue.
TOM SHIELDS: And the historical
data gives us the
seasonal models that we need to
really help make sure that
the forecast reflects the
higher-level variability that
happens at many of
our publishers.
CRAIG MILLER: One of the key
pieces to that I touched upon
in one of those slides is that a
lot if the publisher changes
their tagging architecture
related to moving over to the
new DoubleClick for publishers,
we need to be
aware of that here at Yieldex to
ensure that the seasonality
models that we're applying to
our forecasts accurately
reflect the type of traffic that
we're going to see in the
future related to any traffic
changes that may occur in the
tagging structure itself.
PAUL RASHIDI: OK, great.
Not all publishers are changing
their tagging structure.
But that's good to know,
if they are, to
let you guys know.
JEFF SHAM: Well, great.
One more question, I guess.
So Craig, you mentioned that you
found a better or improved
development paradigm
in the new DFP API.
And I'm sure a lot of our
publishers are interested in
knowing what the key
differences are.
So if you could share
some of the
features that you've found.
CRAIG MILLER: Well, we have
many efficiencies.
As I mentioned, PQL itself gave
us a giant efficiency.
But my developers are able
to actually use more code
commonality or share some
of the implementation by
interacting with multiple
services that all come from a
similar-based interface.
That's allowed us to leverage
development paradigms and have
efficiencies in our
implementation itself that
weren't otherwise possible in
other ad servers APIs or
previous versions of the APIs.
So it's really an internal
benefit for my developers that
they've definitely benefited
from and declared loudly.
We're very happy about it.
PAUL RASHIDI: Great.
JEFF SHAM: Great.
TOM SHIELDS: Now, just in
conclusion for us, we are a
big data analytics company.
We help publishers
forecast, manage,
and price their inventory.
We've got a lot of big clients
who are using this very
successfully with legacy DFP
transitioning to the new DFP.
And we've had great experience
with the new DFP API.
We're delighted with our
implements, and we're
delighted with our partnership
with Google, so thank you.
PAUL RASHIDI: Great.
We're happy as well.
Thank you very much for your
time, gentlemen, and everyone
watching us on the internet
either live or after the fact.
If you'd like more information,
obviously, you
can go to Yieldex's website,
yieldex.com.
And thank you again
for listening.
TOM SHIELDS: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]